In this lecture, we'll be
trying to understand sentiment
of tweets about
the company Apple.
Apple is a computer company
known for its laptops, phones,
tablets, and personal
media players.
While Apple has a
large number of fans,
they also have a
large number of people
who don't like their products.
And they have
several competitors.
To better understand
public perception,
Apple wants to monitor
how people feel over time
and how people receive
new announcements.
Our challenge in this lecture
is to see if we can correctly
classify tweets as being
negative, positive, or neither
about Apple.
To collect the data
needed for this task,
we had to perform two steps.
The first was to collect data
about tweets from the internet.
Twitter data is
publicly available.
And you can collect it
through scraping the website
or by using a special
interface for programmers
that Twitter provides
called an API.
The sender of the tweet might
be useful to predict sentiment.
But we'll ignore it to
keep our data anonymized.
So we'll just be using
the text of the tweet.
Then we need to construct
the outcome variable
for these tweets, which means
that we have to label them
as positive, negative,
or neutral sentiment.
We would like to label
thousands of tweets.
And we know that two
people might disagree over
the correct
classification of a tweet.
So to do this
efficiently, one option
is to use the Amazon
Mechanical Turk.
So what is the Amazon
Mechanical Turk?
It allows people to break tasks
down into small components
and then enables them to
distribute these tasks online
to be solved by people
all over the world.
People can sign up to perform
the available tasks for a fee.
As the task creator,
we pay the workers
a fixed amount per
completed task.
For example, we might pay $0.02
for a single classified tweet.
The Amazon Mechanical
Turk serves as a broker
and takes a small
cut of the money.
Many of the tasks on
the Mechanical Turk
require human intelligence,
like classifying
the sentiment of a tweet.
But these tasks may
be time consuming
or require building
otherwise unneeded capacity
for the creator of the task.
And so it's appealing
to outsource the job.
The task that we put on
the Amazon Mechanical Turk
was to judge the
sentiment expressed
by the following item toward
the software company Apple.
The items we gave them were
tweets that we had collected.
The workers could pick
from the following options
as their response-- strongly
negative, negative, neutral,
positive, and strongly positive.
We represented each
of these outcomes
as a number on the scale
from negative 2 to 2.
We had five workers
label each tweet.
The graph on the right
shows the distribution
of the number of
tweets classified
into each of the categories.
We can see here that
the majority of tweets
were classified as neutral,
with a small number classified
as strongly negative
or strongly positive.
Then, for each tweet, we take
the average of the five scores
given by the five workers.
For example, the
tweet "LOVE U @APPLE"
was seen as strongly
positive by 4 of the workers
and positive by
one of the workers.
So it gets a score of 1.8.
The tweet "@apple @twitter
Happy Programmers' Day folks!"
was seen as slightly
positive on average.
And the tweet "So
disappointed in @Apple.
Sold me a Macbook Air
that WONT run my apps.
So I have to drive
hours to return it.
They won't let me ship it."
was seen as pretty negative.
So now we have a
bunch of tweets that
are labeled with
their sentiment.
But how do we build
independent variables
from the text of a tweet to be
used to predict the sentiment?
In the next video, we'll
discuss a technique
called bag of words
that transforms text
into independent variables.